hello and welcome to the new Walter view
your sauce for everything anime and
manga and today we're here to talk some
Hunter hunter quite specifically to
provide a basic recap for the ongoing
succession will arc now to be perfectly
honest with you this video serves a kind
of selfish purpose because every time I
return to the manga after a long break I
find myself almost 100% lost in the
events that are currently occurring
there's a critical mass of characters
with unique interactions a ton of
abilities to keep in mind and a very
delicate and intricate plot most of
which I've forgotten about by the time I
come back to the manga after a hiatus so
I've decided to try and do something
about that let me say right at the
outset please forgive me with names
characters in hunter hunted notoriously
horrendously romanized names and the
succession war gives us some of the most
obscure ly named individuals in the
series thus far so we'll just we'll be
doing our best with that but in essence
this video is meant to act as something
like a cheat sheet for a very quick
recap on what's going down and why it is
not going to go into extreme details
it's just designed for a general
understanding so let's give this a go
way and sadly I think the simplest place
to start is right where the 2011 anime
left off with the revelation of the
existence of the Dark Continent this
location makes up the large majority of
the world and is home to beings of
unfathomable power two examples of which
bring the chimera ants who provided an
apocalyptic level threat to the human
race as well as nanika the mysterious
being with what seems to be near them at
this abilities as a result the existence
of this continent has been kept highly
secretive from the public and even the
highest-ranking individuals in the world
with knowledge of it required tremendous
resources and permissions to actually
embark on an expedition that most of
which we know of ended in utter disaster
now why is all of this important well
let's take a step back into the world of
humanity to the cocoon Empire where the
entire succession will arc would be set
into motion by their current king now so
be hui Goro who made a sudden
announcement to the world that he would
be sponsoring an expedition to the Dark
Continent but not just for a simple
journey because his intentions were to
expand the cockin Empire and settle on
the continent believing it to be a
reserve of untapped power and resources
for humanity to thrive off and to add to
this NASA bee announces that their guide
will be a man who has previously visited
the dark continent named beyond Netra
in fact not only is beyond being there
before but his late father Isaac
natterer previous chairman of the hunter
Association had also been there on an
expedition of his own but beyond
involvement here Sparks and complicates
matters or more firstly with the
announcement of the
of the cocking Empire the v5 which is a
collective of Nations throughout the
human world immediately see nasibis plan
as a potential threat to humanity and
they then commission the hunter
Association to capture beyond which they
sort of do but beyond is a very clever
man who hands himself over to the
Association and predicted that the v5
would come to endorse the actions of the
cocking Empire which they did because
they saw an opportunity for the
potential spoils of the Dark Continent
in fact this even leads to the v5
becoming the v6 after the cocking Empire
is incorporated into the organization
although with this in mind the former v5
Nations set up a plot to leave the
cocking Empire on one of several large
islands bordering the Dark Continent
which will be referred to as the new
continent around this time chairman
Cheadle and the remaining zodiacs of the
hunter Association watch a video message
from former chairman Network who
expresses his desire for the hunter
Association to successfully explore the
Dark Continent which wins most of them
over and chairman Cheadle begins to
dedicate the organization to the mission
laid out before her the difficulty of
which was designated as rank a and to
put that into some perspective the
difficulty ranking of the Chimera ant
threat the claims net arose life was a
bee switching back to the cocoon Empire
now King Nelson bee has constructed a
mighty seafaring vessel dubbed the black
whale one which has a capacity of
200,000 people stretching across five
absolutely massive decks that is
intended to house the cocoon royal
family a selection of the Empire
civilians as well as representatives
from the hunter Association and the v6
nations for the duration of the journey
and this is the primary stage that the
succession will arc will play upon
because in addition to acquiring
resources from the Dark Continent to
expand his empire nasibi has an ulterior
motive for the journey which is to use
the black whale won as the location for
an official contest to occur between the
14 legal children of nasibi to decide
who will become the next ruler of the
car cane Empire and of course the nature
of victory in such a competition is to
be the sole survivor of the voyage now
here is the most important massive dump
of characters we need to remember from
here on out these are the 14 legal
princes of the cocoon Empire legal
meaning a child of a recognized queen of
which the cocoon Empire has eight and
Prince's being a term used universally
across genders so there are a variety of
female princes involved in the contest
as well so I really hope you like the
word Prince because we're going to be
using it a lot to go through them
quickly in order we have first Prince
Benjamin a highly aggressive and
powerful man who was introduced to us
quite literally wrestling and killing a
lion
second Prince Camilla abuse
four-bit incredibly sadistic and
demonstrably heartless individual with
the fondness for shopping third prince
Angley a short conniving diplomat fourth
prince radnik and wolf boy we'll get
back to him 5th Prince to Peppa a lady
who values modesty humility and science
in equal standing but who is certainly
not above participating in a good
old-fashioned killing game 6th Prince
Tyson who seems to be a genuinely nice
woman who just by participating in the
wall seems to oppose violence oh and
she's also a cult leader 7th Prince
loser Asst who was considered a [ __ ] by
his older siblings but who harbors a
very specific dream of rehabilitating
drug addicts here a substance known as
clean leaf
8th Prince Ali Saleh a notorious
womanizer and glutton who lives only to
engage in intercourse and consumption
ninth Prince Hulkenberg who was a very
vocal opponent in regards to his
family's politics and methods of
tradition and - also presents himself as
a pacifist 10th prince caught show an
outwardly detestable person who seems
early to care for twin sister 11th
Prince forgets ooh who is very much the
opposite of Cacho being very timid and
kind-hearted 12th prince Mimoza and we
know very little about except that she
would seem to be another of the mole
level-headed members of the family 13th
Prince Maryam who is a joyful young lad
with a pet hamster
and finally 14th Prince wobble who
possesses no defined character traits of
any kind because she is a baby all right
that's a lot to take in but the basic
premise of the arc is that by the time
the black whale one has reached the new
continent only one of these individuals
will remain alive and will be crowned as
a successor of the Empire now sadly it's
not quite as simple as an all-out death
match because we're dealing with royalty
here and they need to conduct themselves
in a more appropriate discreet manner
for example during the contest there is
no amnesty for Prince's killing other
Prince's and strict action would be
taken if such an event were discovered
and proved which leads us to how the
princes are expected to actually fight
in this war which is through a more
supernatural element to the contest
old prince is participating are required
to perform the seed urn ceremony in
which they offer a drop of blood into a
jar and a fairy emerges bestowing the
prince in question with an egg which is
fed to them these eggs then eventually
manifest into what I refer to as a
guardian spirit beasts which in
actuality are a type of parasitic man
beast designed to protect and assist
their respective princes in the contest
however they do not act like typical men
based crafted from experienced users in
fact at the commencement of the
succession war the concept of Nan was
completely foreign to all princes
involved meaning that they are for the
most part enabled
control than in VSAT will furthermore
the Guardian beasts are imbued with two
primal instincts the first of which
being that they will not fight and kill
another beast and secondly is that they
will not attack a human who another
guardian beast is currently protecting
these beasts cycle main users also come
with their own unique abilities
conditions and restrictions all of which
were not going to go into here because
my code this video would be far too long
but just be aware that they are the
major weapon of the contest but you know
even after all of this we still have yet
to meet a primary protagonist for the
succession walk which after a lengthy
absence in this series is Cora pika now
at the outset this blonde chap has zero
connection to anything going on
whatsoever
he has no loyalty to the hunter
Association no familiarity with the v6
Nations or any desire to visit the Dark
Continent however he was approached by
Miss I stone a member of the zodiacs and
offered a position amongst them under
the codename of rat filling a position
the Power Stone Hill had left vacant
after resigning news I storm approached
karateka on the recommendation of lei
Oreo who was chosen to fill the position
of ball formerly held by Jing freaks and
to would also be accompanying the
Association to the Dark Continent in any
case miss Iceland enticed graphic art to
provide assistance on this mission by
promising him information on the
individual who possessed the last of the
Scarlet eyes of the Kota clan the
acquisition of which is cropping as
primary purpose in life and as it turns
out the eyes were possessed by 4th
Prince right Nick and my god we will get
into this kind a bit but that was more
than enough for crappy code to become
embroiled in this series of events and
with him crappy cahide a further 5
hunters that he could trust to along
with himself respond to a series of
anonymous recruitment ads to become
bodyguards of one of the princes on the
off-chance at one of these princes was
writing a crappy cahide Biscay na'vi
melody Hanzo and Basha each of whom were
accepted for the role and would become
vital sources of information to cropping
up despite the fact that none of them
were working directly under Surat Nick
as for cropping himself despite his
analysis that he was applying for an ad
from ninth Prince hülkenberg he was
actually hired by queen iter mother of
14th prince wu who had structured the ad
to make prospective applicants believe
she was hülkenberg this was because her
eventual goal was to have Falkenberg
become king and blackmail him with
publicly revealing the secret of the
succession war which would significantly
damage his public image all in order to
ensure the survival of world war this
would also be what karateka would first
learn of the succession war and the true
nature of the danger that he had
involved himself and his associates in
however in order to attain the Scarlet
eyes from Surat Nick this was a more
than except
double risk for him speaking of let's
finally take some time to examine 4th
Prince radnik to call this man a
bloodthirsty sociopath would be a
generous understatement this is a man
who takes the utmost pleasure in the
practice of human slaughter as well as
the collection of body parts which is
why he happens to possess a large number
of the scarlet eyes sought by Cora pika
he is also most certainly the top
candidate amongst this succession war as
presented to the audience surat nick is
a natural genius and throughout the arc
he has been rapidly gaining power at a
terrifying rate to illustrate once the
existence of Nan was made known to him
he managed to master the basic
principles in a handful of days
furthermore he possesses an incredible
quantity of natural aura and was even
able to manifest a second and beast
without even realizing it to make
matters worse right Nik is also a
specialist making him a particularly
dangerous unknown quantity and has
already manifested an ability during his
peril of future which in a very
convoluted manner allows him to see
briefly into the future whilst engaged
in zetsu this ability is also
potentially hinted at being connected to
his second manifested nan beast as the
visions received come from its
perspective but that is pure speculation
because in a state of zetsu in theory he
should not be able to manifest anything
but he is also a specialist so nan rules
out the window but it would seem that
every minute this man is left alone he
continues to gain staggering power
making him an incredible threat to
everyone and everything about the black
whale one Surat Nick would not be the
only prince to learn of nan however and
karappa Co could set a plan in motion
offering to teach nen to a selection of
each of the princes bodyguards in order
to raise their capabilities and work
towards producing a stalemate during the
succession war ten of the princes
accepted this offer with notable ones
who refused being second Prince Camilla
and sixth Prince Tyson however the
princess who accepted then sent two
representatives each to learn then under
carpetas direction and this is where a
lot of the succession war gets muddled
because there are a lot of generically
designed guards and maids each of whom
have their own inner monologues
individual missions and varying
capabilities and while I could go
through them all one by one like I did
with princes I don't think it would be
all that effective but to complicate
things further some of them are already
capable nen users and on top of that
almost all of them are plotting some
sort of shenanigan ring to ensure that
their prince comes out on top as for the
princes themselves so right Nick would
not be the only one to develop his own
inability as Hawken Burke has also
developed a heart Suh known as
possession error although he himself
only has a minimal idea of how it works
but basically hülkenberg can infused the
body of a target of this hour with the
nests of one of his bodyguards first
Prince Benjamin has also developed a hot
suit up to Benjamin baton in which he
receives an inability of a soldier who
has sworn loyalty to him under the
strict conditions that they attended
Cochran's Royal Military Academy and
that they were a member of Benjamin's
private army but through this Benjamin
has thus far inherited three different
and abilities 2nd Prince Camilla wields
a particularly powerful postmortem
nobility that only activates after death
at which point a cat looking beast which
is not hernán beast assigned by the seed
urn appears and devours the life force
of the killer and uses that to revive
Camilla thus rendering her virtually
impossible to kill without a solid
understanding of any other conditions
attached to the heart - and at the time
of this recording other than their
guardian beasts the remaining princes
have yet to demonstrate any further
proficiency in debt now I say remaining
princes because the succession wall
began pretty much immediately after the
back where one departed and currently
has cost the lives of three of the 14
contenders the first of which was 12th
Prince mamas heir who was suffocated by
what is suspected to be a clone
generated by an end user the next victim
would be tenth Prince Cacho who
attempted to escape the battle grounds
for the 11th Prince forget sue although
she discovered that a fail-safe was put
into place that automatically kills
contestants fleeing the war
and while forgets who managed to return
to the ship safely Cacho was killed in
the process
although due to the nature of her nan
beast it has now taken on cara's form
and remains with forget sue and finally
8th Prince Alice Ali was assassinated by
one of Prince Benjamin soldiers after
his nan beast was devoured which
currently leaves us with 11 Prince's
actively engaged in the succession war
now for some more complications we
aren't even done considering the major
players of this arc because our old
favourites the Phantom troop have also
made their way aboard the Blackwell one
with two goals in mind the first of
which is to pursue their traditional
business of thievery with their eyes set
on the treasures of the cocking Empire
and the second is to exact revenge on
former troupe member Hisoka who after
being killed by chrono in Heaven's arena
was subsequently revived by his own
post-mortem men and went on to kill
shall knock and Court opium now all it
should be said that we have had no
visual confirmation that he Soaker has
actually aboard the ship
machi did confirm that he was there in
order to kill the rest of the troop
members and furthermore Hisoka even
hired a lemma zoldak to join the Phantom
troop and attempt to kill him the
vandamm trooper also very relevant to
keep in mind though because they have a
vendetta against karateka
who killed over gain and Popkin odo so
things have the potential to turn into a
gigantic mess aboard the ship to say the
least and that's not even considering
characters like beyond natura who seems
to be cheerfully biding his time
the custody of the hunter Association
but it's highly uncertain if he will
play a role in this because with all of
the throwing Wars at hand we do still
need to remember that the ultimate
destination here is the Dark Continent
which will likely spawn a brand new Ark
featuring the remnants of the characters
that we have here and that kind of does
it for this very abridged version of the
succession will arc so far there's a lot
more intricacy than what I've detailed
here but this should give you a general
idea and leave you capable of jumping
into the manga whenever you see fit and
not being left at a complete loss as to
what's going on if you enjoyed this
video and the content this channel
produced in general then please do
consider donating to the New World
review patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video will
like share or subscribe because it also
helps support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
sharing array takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on the succession war arc
this has been the New World review and
I'll see you next time
[Music]